[Music]
my pants
actually that may have been Oh you're
living the dreams DP yeah
strong highs beautiful dolphin
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again
kiss me like you missed me red what in
the [ __ ] cycle is this
my name is cable I'm here for the kid
what the kid mover died
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be he needs you you're a lot
smarter than I look I ain't lettin cable
kill this kid but I can't do this alone
did you speak up it's hard to hear you
with that pity dick in your mouth we're
gonna form a super duper [ __ ] group
meet him topic morally flexible and
young enough to carry their own
franchise for 10 to 12 years no x-force
isn't that a little derivative you're
absolutely right now let's go get our
[ __ ] on don't call it a comeback
tell me they got that in slow motion
you're the right thing is messy you want
to fight for what's right sometimes you
have to fight dirty matt is why
Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants is
pure pornography oh god I wish I
finished college it lives up to the hype
plus-plus dark yet they probably won't
even make it three yeah why would they
stop it - you killed it
[Music]